[Music]
the thousand going red
yeah digging the music welcome to can
your pet this game is missing esta to me
so many times it's supposed to be really
funny some let's give it a go
my pet name I get to name my pet oh I
got a call at the bottom
hey yeah you go I like yeah alright the
fun I what are we gonna do with you are
you going Brad what is this
all right let's give in some fashion
the father is pretty badass the [ __ ] is
not nope definitely not a chicken Hitler
no I got every guy that'll have to do
yeah I like there we go
mister for sure
[Music]
alright what is this eight what eats
this okay eat some more I don't know how
what is eating but he's liking it hey
you got sauna don't worry about it bro
yeah it's a happy alright I have to keep
fitting him Stefano you are one hungry
son of a [ __ ] there we go
no I can I doesn't like it otherwise
Ivana I do what I gotta do man huh
almost done almost done Stefano doing
okay we're done now you have to work out
you fat son of a [ __ ] play a serious
that's the best you can do
what is this take it huh
you're not even touching it take it take
it
what are you doing Wow one of us class
claw Gingka what what
but how long do I have to do this [ __ ]
[Music]
in the music for the music come on dude
you happy now you son of a [ __ ] I want
this get away
what is this come here dude what is this
yeah
[Music]
good job yeah that's what again
look there's something don't just add
there all right let's take it
take your lightsaber and do you do your
thing